bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
informatique tablette cybersécurité et
smart cities nous allons parler
numérique formation emploi sécurité
quels sont les nouveaux enjeux de saint
quentin en yvelines qui s'apprête à
entrer dans l'ère du très haut débit
on fait le point c'est partout
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines opère sa
transition numérique dans les écoles à
travers l'emploi dans la vie de tous les
jours
le territoire se veut connecté on met un
grand coup d'accélérateur également sur
tout ce qui remplit habilité numérique
parce qu'on le voit aujourd'hui une
voiture la valeur ajoutée que qu'une
entreprise apporte sur le sur le marché
la voiture c'est du numérique
idem sur un avion les gens de chez
peugeot disait nous on engage plus
d'aider des ingénieurs
uniquement automobile en langage des
ingénieurs en informatique experts du
numérique en ce moment c'est on sent
bien qu'ils cette transformation dans
tous les grands secteurs
le new york envahi tous les métiers une
accélération hors norme pour répondre
aux besoins des entreprises et aux
nombreuses propositions de postes non
pourvus le territoire a réagi en 2010
est celui ci lancé son label école du
numérique
devenu en 2010 huit campus numérique
ce sont aujourd'hui plusieurs formations
de bac à bac + 2 voire plus qui sont
proposés développeurs réseaux et
sécurité
community manager à chacun sa spécialité
il y a énormément d'emplois pouvoir on
sait très bien que le numérique c'est le
fin c'est le plus grand qu'on a coutume
de dire notre notre président jean
michel fourgous et plus grand accès
accélérateur de croissance
c'est ce qui procure des la création
d'emplois d'emplois en france est
d'autant plus à saint quentin qui est
quand même une terre une terre très très
importante pour tout ce qui concerne le
monde de l'entreprise ont pour préparer
les informaticiens de demain le
numérique s'apprend dès le plus jeune
âge
chaque petit saint quentinois des douze
communes du territoire sera bientôt
munis d'une tablette
il est important d'adapter les enfants
et donc l'éducation et l'acquisition de
la connaissance dès le plus jeune âge
donc effectivement nous avons au niveau
de saint quentin en yvelines un plan
très ambitieux qui va aller
effectivement de la tablette mais bien
au delà de la tablette tout ce qui
concerne des méthodes d'apprentissage
tout ce qui concerne jusqu'à des jusqu'à
des robots donc c'est quelque chose qui
va être ré
lisez bien entendu en collaboration avec
le monde enseignant parce que le
numérique c'est un outil mais il ne faut
pas que l'outil vous avez déjà un
certain nombre de communes qui ont déjà
impulsé et toutes les communes sont dans
une phase à l'heure actuelle de
réflexion de préparation de leur projet
pour un début de déploiement qui devrait
se réaliser à partir du second semestre
maternelle primaire collège
l'apprentissage du numérique sera
continue jusqu'aux grandes écoles du
territoire 3 i/s estaca universités avec
un master en préparation on a un pôle de
cybersécurité aujourd'hui était en train
d'être mis à l'étude qui sera qui peut
être un des beaux au site de
cybersécurité keita des métiers qui
montent comme ça parce qu'avec le
numérique à l'école comme ça vous avez
intérêt à assurer la cybersécurité
derrière donc il ya un déficit très fort
et l'entreprise bien sûr et se plaignent
que les caisses nationales
on n'a pas prévu cette montée en
puissance donc nous on donne le
complément est on en train de créer
effectivement une des plus belles plate
forme je pense le cyber sécurité pour la
france on est un con cus dédiée à la
cybersécurité et qui devrait accueillir
2000 étudiants
le numérique c'est bien le numérique à
très haut débit c'est encore mieux
la fibre se déploie actuellement sur les
douze communes de territoire et elle est
on s'en doute particulièrement attendait
nous avons la fibre oui oui cesse quand
même plus rapide qu'en
1 ça marche plutôt bien avant quand on
faisait des recherches saab était plus
de temps on a mis ça lui arrive de faire
du télétravail donc c'est mieux pour lui
c'est un petit plus maurepas elancourt
ont été parmi les premières villes de
territoire à être fibrés aujourd'hui
orange et sfr offert le déploiement de
la fibre et du très haut débit sur
l'ensemble des douze communes une
nécessité ressentie très tôt à voisin
nouveau tony la mairie et les écoles et
les entreprises vont eux avaient déjà le
très haut débit voire des fibres et et
il nous restait les habitants puisque
voisin n'était pas du tout fibre et est
donc dans certains endroits
si on était un peu loin du terminal eh
bien ça prenait beaucoup de temps pour
pour utiliser gérait les moyens à la
disposition que les charges et des
documents etc
et c'était me demande vraiment très
forte des habitants parce que il y en a
qui travaillent à la maison déjà et puis
maintenant avec tous les outils modernes
qui se développe c'est difficile de
de ne pas être fibrés en 2015 alexandra
rosetti contexte orange pour le
déploiement de la fibre en 2017
les travaux commencent quartier par
quartier la fibre est installé et là on
a pratiquement terminé
on est on est à 92 % aujourd'hui de
foyers fibrés faire 5000 foyers
on va dire qu'à la fin de l'année tous
voisins le bretonneux aura accès à la
fibre
actuellement le déploiement de la fibre
optique est à l'oeuvre dans plusieurs
communes saint-quentinoise le haut débit
une attente pour les habitants et les
entreprises
nos logiciels en ligne de comptabilité
banques nos serveurs technique qui qui
accueille les données des clients nos
serveurs de développement tout ça est
décentralisée donc du coup on est obligé
d'avoir d'avoir un accès haut débit
ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on est si
vrai et sermo un confort d'utilisation
qui a rien à voir avec les dsl quand
vous commencez à avoir faim d'activité
avec plusieurs collaborateurs le fait de
disposer d'un accès internet qui a
un bon débit c'est un véritable atout le
numérique c'est aussi la
dématérialisation des services publics
là encore le haut débit est exigé pour
une recherche d'emploi près de chez soi
ce qui emploie pourrait faire pour une
question concernant les démarches
administratives peps point ski point fr
le portail espace public service pour
prendre la parole sur les projets
développés par l'agglomération eskimos
point ski point fr et paysages points ce
qui point fr c'est vrai que je me
déplace pas forcément puisque il ya
internet quand même pratique pas la
déclaration d'impôt la sécurité sociale
la cave recherche d'emploi ce qui
signifiait
théâtre mais aussi pour procéder à la
rénovation énergétique de son habitat
accéder au portail des associations ou
encore pour une sortie culture désormais
tout se fait derrière l'ordinateur
[Musique]
connecté et intelligente les vignes
seront bientôt un consortium
d'entreprises oeuvre à la sécurisation
des objets connectés
la start up m to m en fait partie elle
prépare l'éclairage public de demain le
ski cud ici des start up dont le projet
est soutenu par le territoire l'univers
de m to m
les objets connectés en 2015 son
président julien fessard à imaginer
l'éclairage intelligent on a développé à
la fois un module une plateforme qui
permet de piloter en toute simplicité
l'éclairage public en intégrant en fait
des données qui sont vraiment
particulière à la situation d'un site
une zone d'habitation nos zones
d'activités un parc et pour chacun le
bon éclairage au bon moment l'éclairage
connectés envoie et reçoit des données
vers une plateforme centralisée
données de circulation données
météorologiques
l'éclairage s'adapte l'exemple d'un
carrefour qui se situe dans une zone
pour laquelle on va moduler l'éclairage
à la baisse de barbe à notre
connaissance de niveau de fréquentation
mais si jamais un accident intervient
sur ce carrefour
on doit être capable de le sur éclairé
pour éviter un suraccident en cerise sur
le gâteau les économies d'énergie et de
maintenance mais les domaines des objets
connectés comporte un enjeu de sécurité
c'est pourquoi le projet de ville
intelligente de m tu aimes se développe
en collaboration avec le projet pak lido
patrie d'eau qui a pour vocation de
créer des nouveaux algorithmes de
cryptage qui sont voués à être les mai
prochain standard pour l'internet des
objets un consortium de huit partenaires
français coordonné par airbus cyber
sécurité la sécurité au niveau de
l'internet des objets a vraiment des
particularités c'est hyper singulier
notamment le fait que ce sont des masses
d'objets ce sont des objets pour
lesquels potentiellement on a un accès
physique à l'objet donc tout ça ça ça
crée des vulnérabilités qui
malheureusement ne peuvent pas être
combattu avec les algues au rythme
actuel et les systèmes de sécurité
actuelles algorithmes de cryptage module
d'intelligence artificielle des
sentinelles qui auront pour mission de
détecter des comportements anormaux ou
suspects depuis l'objet jusqu'à son
application
la cybersécurité rempart crucial
aujourd'hui de l'internet et qui ne
relève plus du film d'espionnage ou de
romans de science fiction
les menaces sont bien réels nous sommes
allés chez antemeta à guyancourt
recueillir la parole d'un expert anti
mites à aiguillon cours
l'entreprise créée en 1995 a développé
cinq piliers d'activités parmi lesquels
les expertises réseaux infrastructures
data management solutions type est sapée
et cyber sécurité actuellement il ya
deux vecteurs d'attaqué principaux est
assez différent des heures il ya le
premier facteur d'attac qui est une
attaque qui cible les équipements
réseaux qui sont plutôt fait par des
professionnels qui vise à prendre la
main sur les équipements ou placer une
porte dérobée sur ces crises équipements
et les hackers vont revendre ce point
d'accès à d'autres équipes qu'on en tout
cas envie de nuire à l'entreprise
le deuxième vecteur attaques ciblent les
utilisateurs finaux à travers des mails
piéger des pièces jointes à cliquer il
faut bien voir que ces mails piégé mais
sur lennar on envoie une foultitude qui
sont faits de manière automatique et
assez grossier quand c'est fait par des
professionnels c'est vraiment très très
précis
on prend forcément des précautions mais
s'est passé contre auxerre et a passé
prévention ce matin j'ai encore reçu 1
un message qui disait que je n'avais pas
réglé mon crédit alors que j'ai aucun
crédit
il fallait que je donne ma carte des
choses que je n'ai pas fait je voudrais
pas comme ça paraît un peu bizarre où
compter les fautes d'orthographe
je clique pas j'aurais surtout mon
commentaire la sécurité de nos
coordonnées bancaires on est un peu
sceptique comme tout peut se dire à tes
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui essaye une
facture que vous attendiez et comportant
de véritables informations vous est
adressée sauf qu'une charge active et
figure des malwares permettant de
récupérer les mots de passe de collecter
les informations importantes en vue
d'une future attaque chez soi mais aussi
en entreprise
nous sommes tous concernés dans une
société chaque utilisateur est visé la
sécurité des systèmes d'information est
à prendre en compte la sécurité et
ajuste un nouveau risque à gérer mais à
gérer au même titre que tous les risques
comme les risques industriels comme les
risques de pollution comme le risque de
la coupure électrique
une fois qu'on va commencer il faut pas
rêver à chiffrer ce risque on voit à peu
près l'argent qu'il faut mettre à côté
un coût que les entreprises doivent
prendre en compte dès le départ car lors
d'une cyberattaque
l'entreprise peut tout perdre document
processus de production de facturation
de fonctionnement de l'entreprise
une société se remet difficilement d'une
attaque majeure une entreprise sa durée
de survie après à l'incident de sécurité
majeur bien sûr ces cinq ans
c'est qu'on ne remonte pas la pente on
va perdre de l'argent même si on l'a re
des mers quinze jours après on n'est pas
à sa pleine efficacité quinze jours
après et ce tout ce retard s'accumule on
dépense de l'argent pour corriger
l'incident donc on ne dépense pas de
l'argent pour préparer l'avenir
on perd de l'efficacité donc tout
doucement on creuse son trou
donc on meurt pas le lendemain d'un
incident de sécurité mais dans les
années qui suivent on est en difficulté
le terme est un peu fort mais on est en
difficulté dans la sécurité il n'y a pas
que du matériel
il ya d'abord des hommes et des femmes
il ya d'abord des processus il ya
d'abord des façons de travailler
il ya des façons de travailler qui nous
mettent en danger et des façons de
travailler qui nous met mois en danger
et donc systématiquement pour l'évaluer
pour se prémunir en premier lieu mesurer
les menaces et les tic d'attac la
fonction du soc
la tour de contrôle de la société celui
ci rassemble toutes les alertes ici le
soc mutualisent les bases de
connaissances concernant les incidents
de sécurité des clients d'antemeta
notamment les pme des processus de
détection et de réactions aux alertes
maintes fois répété qu'ils permettent
des réponses optimum
comme bon nombre d'entreprises sur saint
quentin en yvelines
antemeta recrute une centaine de postes
sur divers métiers de l'informatique
sont à pourvoir
donc n'hésitez pas à postuler à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]